[Musique]
cyrille melchior président du
département et rené mandon maire des
avirons signer le pacte de solidarité
territoriale ce jeudi 23 août à la
mairie de la vigne lancée à l'initiative
du département ce pacte de solidarité
territoriale est le fruit d'un
partenariat avec les communes c'est un
grand moment parce que j'ai vu les
réalisations de cette belle commune des
réalisations concrètes au service des
habitants de cette belle commune des
avirons et il est important que le
département accompagne les efforts de
cette municipalité
la municipalité recevra une enveloppe de
2,4 millions d'euros une bouffée
d'oxygène pour ronnie monde ont toutes
les les contraintes qu'on a au niveau du
budget on ne peut prouver plutôt avancé
et je pacte de solidarité deux millions
trois cent cinquante trois mille euros
eh ben c'est une bouffée d'oxygène et on
pouvoir faire avancer quand même trois
projets de chaînes leur territoire déjà
un premier projet l'aménagement d'un
parking et qui permettra de fluidifier
le centre ville ensuite il y aura là au
niveau de la cuisine centrale mais
sonorisation de cette cuisine centrale
et pour boucler notre 2 millions à toi
et on aura l'aménagement d'un chemin
cabris qui en a très bien besoin
la rencontre s'est achevée par la pose
de la première pierre du futur parking
qui sera aménagé en centre ville grâce
au pacte de solidarité territoriale
[Musique]